Kylie Jenner may think getting her  wisdom teeth removed sucks but she has  it made with the cutest little helper  taking care of her her baby girls stormy  yeah  Kylie took to Instagram on Monday to  share a few adorable videos post-op  cuddled up in bed with her two-year-old  daughter I'm obsessed with it the duo  made it out of bed and nurse stormy  helped her mom down the stairs in her  Louis Vuitton slippers stormy even  showed off her counting skills 11 12 13  yeah stormy has been such a sweetie  helping her mom recover but she can also  be hilariously savage so we're watching  frozen too for the first time especially  when it comes to interrupting movie time  I just turned to tell her I love her  [Music]  hey and get this  stormy has even started calling her  mommy by her first name that's not my  name my name's mommy  [Music]  [Music]